amazing workers and thinkers and they
really distinguished themselves in a sea
of mediocrity from a lot of other
institutions and then also yes so good
good work all those don't see these but
my my husband and I send our kids to a
classical Lutheran school but is also
staffed by quite a few Hillsdale
graduates and my daughter's fifth grade
teacher has been directing her recently
in memorizing the entirety of Pericles
funeral oration just you know not what a
lot of fifth graders are doing and she
and one of her classmates recently were
encouraged to draw an illustrated
children's Odyssey so that the younger
students at the school could learn the
joys of the Odyssey and then my third
grader her teachers also at Hillsdale
grad and she has just made Greek
mythology so exciting for this third
grader and my daughter recently made a
board game based on the lives of Greek
gods and goddesses and we pay our kids
money based on whether they answer
jeopardy questions correctly or not
and so she is just really doing well in
the mythology category and the ten cents
each time it's very exciting but I just
want to thank you for your support of
this institution that has meant so much
to my husband and me and and in our work
and in our lives and also as I mentioned
that went to University of Colorado and
I am a native a very proud native of
Colorado and I know that many of you
here are from Colorado
to the extent that when people ask me
where I'm from I still say Colorado and
I haven't actually lived here in 20
years but I just refused to accept the
idea that I'm from anywhere other than
Colorado and my parents live in Douglas
County and my sisters in Denver and I
have a large extended family here so it
is so nice to be in beautiful Colorado
and I hope you all appreciate the
beautiful place that you get to live as
well a little different in Virginia and
also a pretty place but no mountains and
none of the none of the lifestyle and
beauty that you all have here so okay on
Monday night I was on special report TV
is not my natural medium as you probably
can figure out I prefer to write and
breaking news is a particularly
stressful situation I like to think
about what I'm gonna say and then write
it out and then rewrite what I'm gonna
say well on Monday that was when the
special counsel referred some wrongdoing
to a local FBI branch and they raided
the president's personal attorney's
offices home and a hotel room to seize
all those things and we were being asked
to respond to it in real time and I had
this I was actually having a lot of fun
with it because this is one of those
stories that I have been following quite
a bit I have very different thoughts on
everything than most people in DC about
this larger story it was fun to respond
but it was also just so surreal you know
we were watching the president speak
about the violation of civil liberties
and what a disgrace it is that's going
on and I almost felt like I was outside
myself understanding this is a really
serious moment in time and it's really
just so surreal to have a president who
just says what's on his mind for better
for worse
he just says what's on his mind and he
just sort of says things that you don't
expect a politician to say but what's
weird about the moment is also that we
have a media that distorts what's
happening and that also contributes to
these feelings of Surrealism
that I think a lot of people are
experiencing they sort of see what's
going on with their own eyes and then
they listen to a media distort and
contextualize things in a way that
doesn't match with reality so I was
reading
story about Chuck Todd in Politico
recently and it was built around how the
president had used very intemperate
rhetoric to personally attack him
calling him a son of us something and
Chuck Todd had this quote that just
stuck with me he said our credibility is
being challenged now by the President
and maybe it's a tactic maybe it's the
same old same old but one of their
strongest arrows in their quiver is the
media's coverage of the Iraq war and so
we can't afford to get a big story wrong
basically twice in a decade
twice in I guess a generation he went on
the collective press cores coverage of
Vietnam and Watergate gave the media its
credibility an interesting perspective I
don't know you know he said if we blow
this moment it could be something that
will pay a price for for a generation
and I'm sitting there thinking yes Chuck
Todd that would be very bad for your
credibility if you blew a really big
story such as oh I don't know the entire
2016 campaign and election that would be
really bad and to like pretend like that
didn't happen and to pretend that people
didn't notice what was going on I mean
how many times did was there's this
media consensus about what was going on
that didn't match with reality as
evidenced by the result of the election
but even if the election hadn't gone
that way it would have been just as true
that the media were telling a false
story because it was a clean it was a
close enough election that they could
have sort of gotten away with it but
rather than responding to that
humiliating and discrediting coverage of
2016 with a genuine admission of guilt
a return to fact-based reporting as
opposed to narrative pushing and making
systemic changes to improve diversity
and newsrooms newsrooms responded
instead by getting worse and it's really
weird you'd think you go through an
event like that you have no option but
to admit you need to fix some things and
instead we've seen media get just more
unhinged and more history
ricky'll yesterday a media reporter at
CNN was bragging about the chyron of the
day at CNN
so Chiron is like at the very bottom of
the screen on your TV it's like a
caption or something that describes
what's going on and yeah and so like in
recent years CNN has taken to just using
that Chiron to attack Republicans and
mostly actually just Trump to attack
Trump so they'll say Donald Trump said
something and that's a lie you know and
they put it in the chyron and it would
be one thing I mean I don't think people
think of Donald Trump is the most
precise read rotation so it would be one
thing if they were doing that across the
board like if you like your health care
plan you can keep your health care plan
and that's a lie you know it'd be one
thing if they were doing it for
everybody of all politicians but they
just do it mostly with Trump and
Republicans but the one yesterday said
Trump's anger over raid surpasses
previous tantrums that's a really mature
chyron that you should brag about
putting on your media outlet Emmys weird
because CNN I think used to be thought
of as a media outlet that at least aimed
toward objectivity and aimed to have a
sort of calm sense about it and they
chose to throw that away I don't know
how that's working out for them but this
was a reference this supposed tantrum
was a reference to Trump not taking
kindly to an out-of-control FBI and
Department of Justice rating the offices
of his personal attorney as you might
imagine might not go over well with
people particularly because
attorney-client communications which are
privileged were seized that's a serious
issue but our media aren't really
interested in exploring those serious
issues instead of they just want to do
point scoring against Republicans and
Trump in particular Alan Dershowitz who
I think has been an admirable exception
to a lot of this is a genuine liberal
who actually believed what he was saying
for many years and has been raising
concerns about these investigations that
don't have a strong legal basis and he
said yesterday and a piece he published
many civil libertarians have remained
silent about potential violations of
president Trump's rights because they
strongly disapprove of him and his
policies that is a serious mistake
because these violations establish
precedents that lie around like loaded
guns capable of being aimed at other
targets it doesn't take a huge intellect
to realize if they can do this to the
president they can do it to you but we
have a one-sided media environment that
seems to me to be getting worse every
day
conservative and constitutional
viewpoints are throttled while
progressive viewpoints are amplified and
coordinated a couple of weeks ago one of
my colleagues at Fox critiqued one of
the children that is being used by
anti-gun activists to attack gun rights
she issued an unnecessary tweet she
quickly apologized for her intemperance
in a genuine way but it didn't matter
the gun the people who opposed gun
rights refused the apology and they
pressured companies to stop advertising
on her show now in an adult world
children telling corporations to bully
people for wrong think would be
dismissed as ridiculous but in our world
the corporation's quickly succumbed it's
a very reminiscent of what happened just
a few weeks prior when Delta Airlines
responded to bullying by attacking NRA
members and removing a benefit in the
very grand display of virtue signaling
and all of this you know I think people
really need to think about what these
stories have in common which is what
actually happened is there was a
horrific shooting in Florida were
literally dozens of times federal state
and local authorities were warned about
someone who they thought was a problem
and it wasn't even sometimes the
warnings were like we think this person
is violent and a problem sometimes the
warnings were as specific as this person
with this name is going to shoot up this
school with this name I mean you can't
get a more specific warning than that
and for some reason the agreed upon
response by many people in the media was
that the fault lied with NRA members and
that the response to massive
catastrophic government
to defend its citizens should be a
removing of rights of self-defense
that's insane
that makes no sense at all and yet it's
actually what you see in most media
coverage of what's going on yesterday
and today I guess we were mentioning
Mark Zuckerberg the CEO of Facebook was
testifying on the hill and most of the
questions were as Cheryl pointed out
from grandstanding senators with limited
knowledge of Facebook or how it works
but I did like the line of questioning
from two senators Ted Cruz of Texas and
Ben Sasse of Nebraska who asked
important questions about how Facebook
defines safe speech and unsafe speech
and how they understand their role in
protecting free speech and how they have
a one-sided crusade regarding speech the
senators pointed out how conservative
viewpoints are routinely silenced while
leftist viewpoints are amplified and
never silenced Twitter's CEO and Twitter
is this you know huge social media
platform where a lot of ideas are spread
and disseminated and where a lot of the
bullying takes place the corporations
that respond to the bullying by removing
advertising are usually just pressured
on Twitter so it's an important medium
even if not a lot of people are on there
so the CEO of Twitter linked approvingly
to a threatening article about how the
left should just model itself in total
after California's left and just destroy
the right compromises over the right
simply must be destroyed and silenced
which is a threatening thing free social
media CEO to say hey check this article
out it's really a good read when you're
not in his in his viewpoint
despite their numbers the strength of
their arguments and their political
power conservatism is struggling because
every institution in America is making
it difficult to get the message out they
distort what we say they apply double
standards and frequently just silencing
conservatives is the easiest way to deal
with us it's much harder to engage
arguments so when we think about how we
got here
I think people rightly understand that a
lot of this
happens as a result of what's happening
in academia but I also get a little
frustrated when people say like how did
things happen like this I was talking
with my dear colleague Charles
Krauthammer many months ago who was
saying that you know he's been in the
Punda tree business for a really long
time and he's always been predicting
doom and gloom
if conservative values are not upheld he
said after a while he was wondering if
maybe he wasn't being melodramatic
because it seemed like the country was
doing fine and was wealthy healthy
people seem to be largely content and in
recent years he'd come to realize that
in fact he had been right that failure
to uphold conservative values was having
a serious problem for the culture and
that many of the predictions he'd made
about moral rot were in fact coming true
I think conservatives should have far
more confidence in their predictive
powers frequently and conservatives
predict some bad affect will come about
with a change in policy you can think of
thousands of these examples but think
about how there were changes to welfare
benefits decades ago we're coming from a
good place people thought that it was
unfair that women couldn't get welfare
benefits for them and their children
unless they were married so they removed
the requirement that merit that you
should be married if you're getting
welfare benefits for your family and
conservatives said they understand why
you would do that but it might actually
result in worse problems if the father
is no longer considered integral to a
family and he can just kind of check out
of course you can imagine what the
response was to this line of argument
you people are evil bigoted racist is
there nothing you wouldn't do to hurt
poor people and progressives won the day
now of course we know that not only were
the Conservatives right they were they
were more right than they even knew the
situation in terms of family
disintegration among lower classes is
horrifically bad not having fathers
involved in in the raising of children
is causing serious problems for young
for young boys and girls and we have now
decades of data to show this but there
are no apologies offered for all those
slurs that were hurled at conservatives
but never mind
my point is conservatives should have
more confidence in their predictions and
for decades conservatives have been more
about the decline of education in
government primary schools as well as in
academia they said it was causing
serious problems turning away from true
education and adoption of many
progressive ideas some have been warning
about this at least since the 60s and
then they act surprised when they see
what's happening on college campuses and
it is a bad situation right now and I
think it's worth going over a little bit
of it
over 90% of America's top colleges
regulate campus free speech one-third
employs severely restrictive policies
according to fire the foundation for
individual rights and education
that monitors this so one of the main
ways that this can happen even is
through policing of what are called
micro aggressions this is where you say
something nice but the ID argument is
that you're actually being racist or
sexist so if you say I'm impressed that
you're majoring in economics to a woman
like myself who majored in economics
that might be sexist because you're
implying women can't handle the math
that's silly but at least you kind of
understand where what the thinking is
there other examples are far less
defensible like if you say America is a
land of opportunity that could be very
hurtful to someone who hasn't made it to
the top 1%
of America
and supposedly this you know
marginalizes people who haven't had the
same success as elites the idea is
completely out of control and infecting
the larger popular culture this week
there was a big brouhaha about The
Simpsons which is a show I don't watch
but my husband I believe has every
episode memorized and there is a
character appoo who in my limited
viewing I believe it's the far and away
the best character on The Simpsons he
runs the convenience store he is
fundamentally decent and honest and
hard-working and nice but a comedian
just put out a documentary saying that
he's problematic because he reinforces
stereotypes about South Indian
immigrants to the United States which I
would think what is the stereotype that
they're awesome because op who is so
awesome in this show but people really
decided that this was a real serious
problem for The Simpsons The Simpsons to
their credit responded in their TV show
by dismissing the criticism which itself
then was problematic because they're
supposed to know you're always supposed
to respond to people with hurt feelings
by kick by catering to those hurt
feelings and they declined to do that
but back on campus a new night Gallup
poll shows that 30% of college students
favored outright censorship of
politically incorrect views 30% is bad
but it's really bad when you realize
that it was just 22% 8 years ago I'm
sorry just 22% two years ago the William
F Buckley program at Yale recently
commissioned a survey about attitudes
toward free speech on campus they
interviewed 800 students all across the
country and they showed that by a margin
of 51 percent to 36 percent students
favor their school having speech codes
to regulate speech for students and
faculty 63% favored requiring professors
to employ trigger warnings to alert
students to material that might be
discomforting and you know I I think
that um you know you're familiar with
trigger warnings and when it's discussed
it for people who have legitimate
post-traumatic stress disorder which
usually arises from actual trauma like
serving in a war and seeing something
really horrific and then struggling upon
your return to a non war Society
and you can even argue that to some
extent PTSD as diagnosed in the military
is itself overly diagnosed but the idea
that being a freshman at Swarthmore
requires a trigger warning no matter how
horrendous you think colleges are I
think that's a ridiculous claim to make
and one-third of students polled could
not identify the first amendment as the
part of the Constitution that dealt with
free speech thirty-five percent said
that the First Amendment does not
protect something they call hate speech
while thirty percent of self-identified
liberal students said the First
Amendment is itself outdated it's not a
good situation so it's a regular case to
hear about conservatives many of whom
aren't even really that conservative
getting shouted down when trying to give
a speech at a campus and
administration's aren't really doing
much to protect these speakers protect
the rights of students who want to
listen to these speakers not really
doing much at all with a few notable
exceptions how much to note I get
invited to speak at college campuses and
I have yet to be yelled at and I feel
like I'm doing something really wrong so
I'm gonna work on that see what I can do
to improve the situation but but I think
people need to focus on the bigger
picture you know free speech isn't the
end of itself it exists for a much
bigger more important reason and it's
about intellectual freedom and the right
of many of the right of man to seek
truth and when you look at our First
Amendment the one that 30 percent of
college students can't identify what's
in it it looks at so many of the
freedoms necessary for man to pursue and
identify truth it is difficult to
determine truth and we would need the
freedom of the press freedom of speech
and most importantly freedom of religion
in order to pursue truth the founders
knew that was so important that this was
built in at the very beginning and a
turn away from that very much hurts
intellectual freedom I was reading one
scholar who put it well shouting down a
speaker Rob's listeners of the
opportunity to hear and learn and Rob's
the speaker of his own speech a central
reason to value open debate is its
capacity to show us the truth
even if only by voicing errors that make
the truth easier to apprehend free
speech is central to political and moral
reasoning in which citizens express
their conclusions and weigh them against
competing claims if you believe in
self-government you need free speech for
an informed populace that makes wise and
Prudential decisions and that does mean
that provocative and controversial
thinkers need space to express
themselves and to be spoken against when
you look at the progressive agenda which
is for many about elite bureaucratic
control of the people control of the
means of determining truth is key for
advancing their agenda keeping people
from being able to practice their
religion for real is key to the
progressive agenda limiting the press
such as we saw with that citizens united
battle where the government tried to
keep people from publishing negative
information about Hillary Clinton I
think people forget the Citizens United
ruling was really about whether you had
the right to publish critical
information a critique of Hillary
Clinton prior to an election in which
she was running for office and the
government argued that you should not
have the right to do that which is just
amazing and of course limiting discourse
that we see in the culture is all part
of this same task I mentioned about the
time that we spent at Hillsdale and when
I first arrived on campus John Miller
who heads the journalism program was
giving me a tour and I asked him to
explain to me a little bit about the
dress code that students are required to
follow and he said what are you talking
about and you know I coming from
University of Colorado where I remember
one of my fellow students won a contest
the contest was can you wear the same
outfit every day he could it was really
disgusting by the end of the year sorry
every day for it for a full year and he
did it he was wearing like really nasty
shorts and a sweatshirt and he wore them
every day for a year so when I think of
college dress code that was more my
experience and Here I am on Hillsdale
and the girls are wearing these lovely
dresses and pumps and the men are
wearing suit jackets and they're all
just so adult like and John Miller
explained to me that there is no dress
code
at Hillsdale they do that voluntarily
and I think it shows something very
important about the students at
Hillsdale and how they are treated and
it relates to how they read before you
before you discuss things with them in
class just they're not infantilized like
so many students that so many colleges
are you know when all that talk about
microaggressions safe spaces
acquiescence to feelings it isn't just
the university's fault by the way it's
also a result of the decline of family
size and the resultant helicopter
parenting that we've witnessed in recent
decades this these bubbles of protection
for students if you treat students like
children they'll act accordingly and
they do you probably heard the story a
couple years ago about how some office
at university Yale University's
intercultural Affairs Committee put out
a memo asking people not to wear
offensive Halloween costumes you know
don't dress up as a Native American you
might offend a Native American don't
dress up as a pirate you know how
pirates get they're very sensitive and
so and this Yale faculty member named
Erica Christakis sent an email in
response which said have we lost faith
in young people's capacity in your
capacity to exercise self censure
through social norming and also in your
capacity to ignore or reject things that
trouble you it's a good question she
meant it actually rhetorically but it
turned out that they had lost faith in
young people's capacity and she and her
husband who are both working at the
University were bullied she ended up
being forced out of her job the
University did not punish the students
who were screaming at her and her
husband or bullying them they in fact
responded by allocating fifty million
dollars in diversity training or
something to that effect and my favorite
thing is that Erica Christakis was a was
called a housemaster which is like a
leadership position at Yale they've
renamed the Masters because they of
course as you know clearly it's a racist
term
unless you know Latin even a little bit
of Latin where master comes from
Magister meaning teacher so they really
showed the Latin people who's boss there
and of course nobody knows Latin so the
only possible explanation for I you'd be
called a master is racism so they've
changed it to something else I don't
know what they changed it to but that
was the actual response from Yale when
the response should have been exactly
the opposite there is some evidence that
this isn't working out as well for
universities as many in the media
suggests it does my husband Mark
Hemingway has written a lot about the
protests at the University of Missouri
that broke out in 2015 they were
originally related to black lives matter
but then they became mostly about
administration at the University of
Missouri and worker benefits there were
hunger strikes the footballs team struck
or they did a the football team did a
boycott they a professor was caught on
video encouraging violence against media
that were covering the protests
literally and the Chancellor of Mizzou
resigned the president of the entire
University of Missouri system also
resigned
Spike Lee made a film about it but it
turns out that the way that people
responded the people in the real world
responded to the University of Missouri
is that they received your they expect
to an increase in enrollment instead
they got a fifteen hundred student drop
in enrollment for the next year they had
to close for dorms the next year they by
the end of the year's enrollment was
down 6.1 percent from the previous year
they were projecting a seven point four
percent drop the next year and it's just
getting worse they had to cut 55 million
dollars out of their budget to make up
for the tuition shortfall which they
also responded to by increasing tuition
suggests they maybe need to learn a
little bit about supply and demand
but universities have stopped teaching
economics in any way that makes sense a
long time ago so they can be forgiven
for this error I guess but considering
that the initial protests were about
worker benefits it's also worth noting
that they had to layoff four hundred
university employees
which is not also bad because as I think
we know a lot of administration's are so
bloated administrative Lea they have
over 13,000 full-time employees at
Missouri one for every two students or a
little bit more than two students of the
next fall this other professor William
deressa which wrote a piece for the
American scholar about teaching in a
woman's school recently where speech was
stifled he begins his piece by talking
about a young student who says she
quickly figured out she had to hide her
Christianity from students and faculty
and it really got him thinking about the
climate at liberal universities at one
point he notes that the schools are
really religious institutions you know
not Methodist or Catholic but that they
are designed to protect the religion of
the elite sort of a religion of success
and he says the link with political
correctness which isn't a natural link
to that to that religious value of
success is a fig leaf to cover this sort
of competitive individualism of
meritocratic neoliberalism which
worships individual success above all so
this political correctness ideology
provides a moral cover beneath which
undergraduates can prosecute their
careerist projects undisturbed he says
between that groupthink and the radical
individualistic success plan follows the
actual core purpose of liberal education
that's what falls away inquiry into the
fundamental human questions undertaken
through rational discourse which you
don't get to do with the us talk of PC
consensus which is not about argument or
the them talk of by two pourous rage
which dominates most of our media and
social media so lost in this new higher
education religion is inquiry into the
fundamental human questions what shall
we do and how shall we live those
questions threaten the radical
individual success religion and its
values and they threatened the certain
confident orthodoxy of political
correctness the core purpose of a
liberal education he says raises the
possibility that there are different
ways to think and that is threatening to
the progressive agenda seems well put
there are various ways to respond
a lot of conservatives have put a lot of
thought into this Stanley curse writes
about the free speech problem on campus
and I was reading a piece of his where
he talked about his game plan for what
to do which is colleges and universities
ought to adopt a policy on freedom of
expression then they need to
systematically educate members of their
faculty to make sure that they
understand these principles and then
they have a responsibility for assuring
free expressions they need to be held
accountable when these things fail you
know and so on and so forth but I'm also
a bit frustrated by how long it can take
some conservatives to wake up to the
reality and the the seriousness of what
is going on they know academia is a
disaster but people keep sending their
kids to the same schools without giving
them the tools before that that they
need to survive and thrive at those
schools last week there was a small
story that I still think was significant
in Washington DC the Atlantic Monthly
claims to not be partisan and to have no
quick it's not actually true but that's
what they had been claiming up until
last week it has really no conservatives
it has two people it tries to claim are
conservative who occasionally wade into
conservative like the Outer Banks of a
conservative ideology David Frum and an
another guy there but they hired Kevin
Williamson who had who had left the
national would left National Review to
go work with them he's a belligerent
trump critic but conservative and
pro-life and they fired him days later
after a internal mob and external mob
demanded it and their cowardly editor
Jeffrey Goldberg acquiesced by the way I
was in Jeffrey Goldberg's offices he's a
very nice guy and I was so impressed he
had this picture he had a Charlie Hebdo
poster in his office and the idea is
that he is someone who would withstand
even threats of Islamist violence in
defense of freedom of the press and he
couldn't even take a few days of Planned
Parenthood bullying so I really hope
that he had the very least has taken
down the poster at the Charlie Hebdo
poster just for his own Integrity's for
his own sake but the got rid of Kevin
Williamson and it was in this conned
texts that the Twitter CEO pushed out
that article about the left crushing the
right they have this idea there is no
need to debate or seek the truth or even
compromise just crush the opposition and
move on and that is where we are now and
it's awful and I think we should stop
pretending it's not that bad which is
top pretending it's acceptable and as
bad as things are now yes okay great
as bad as things are now people even 10
to 20 years ago things were kind of bad
on campus then too but they were far
more amenable to free speech at that
time so the decline is happening quickly
I keep thinking what's gonna happen in
10 years when people come out of an of a
climate in ten years they they get
control of all these institutions it is
going to be insanely awful even by
today's standards my colleague at the
Federalist Ben Dominick wrote about this
last week saying consider the major
hires the Washington Post New York Times
and the network's have made since the
2016 election the editions
overwhelmingly haven't been Trump fans
they have been different critics of the
president and the administration
occasionally from a slightly more
rightward position Kevin Williamson was
consistent with this the point is that
the audience for all their errors about
the diversity of viewpoints and how
that's important really just once their
existing views re expressed to them in
different forms and by different voices
if you get through the diversity veneer
you'll find the same rule no wrong think
can be tolerated to these religious
institutions of colleges and the media
constitutionalists and conservatives are
abject heretics and they treat us as
such it is time to stop trying to
pretend that they are open to discourse
or that working with them is where you
become like the one token person at
their institution will effect the change
that is necessary for the Republic for
those with views placing them on the
right the only way to win in my view is
to not play this game anymore the only
way to win is to build up our own
platforms and institutions our own hills
dales our own TV shows our own
publications that's why my publication
the Federalists exists that's why
Hillsdale exists and I hope you all
commit to recognizing the seriousness of
the
ahead of us and the work needed to save
the Republic and her values and I'm very
glad to be working with you all on this
Thank You mrs. Hemingway we now have
time for a few questions please raise
your hand and wait for the microphone to
be brought to you hi Bill Dedmon Jordan
Peterson has come into the news lately
with regard to a lot of the things
you're addressing I wonder if you have
some comments on him so I am reading
through his book the 12 rules for living
as I what it's called right now and I'm
enjoying it I'm not I'm not like a
complete fan of him in large part
because I myself am a Christian and I
don't love his approach to Christianity
but I find him a really fun and
provocative thinker to study and I think
what's interesting about him also is
that he is having people are responding
to him and are being forced to respond
to him because he's such a heretic
heretics or dissidents can be really
effective for influencing discourse and
he comes from liberal academic
environment
he has just through the course of his
studies and his practices come to
realize there are serious problems about
the limits of free expression and how
they threaten the survival of a free
society so I actually do think he's
worth reading not reading uncritically
but I think he is making an impact for a
reason which is that he's forcing some
questions that people have to take
seriously and boy do people find him
frustrating on the left which also can
be but they but they're sort of forced
to engage with him and at least talk
about where they don't like him and
that's a very helpful thing as well my
question is how can we consumers
pushback when we see the news media make
egregious mistakes like on the nightly
news it's either sins of omission or
Commission or both I used to live in
Chicago and I wrote dick Durbin because
I didn't he didn't care what I said but
his 20-something interns might have
learned something so should I take any
time and write NBC CBS all these guys
and say hey guys you blew it or does it
really not matter cuz they make money
cuz they'll let people support their
advertisers I'm not sure if I know the
answer to the question but I do think
there is value in in responding to false
news that you see from media outlets
and I recommend doing it like if people
receive no pushback there they're
existing in a lot of echo chambers where
everybody affirms for them that the way
they view things is correct
and when someone pierces through that
bubble it can be very effective and I
also think it's important when you're
doing that that you speak nicely and you
don't allow them to tune you out because
I think it's very frustrating and I
sometimes get filled with rage sometimes
i watch things I'm like this is the
worst thing I've ever seen and I'm so
angry but before I write the note to the
reporter and say so by the way when you
have made this factually incorrect
statement I would try and calm down so
that I don't just say what's actually
what I'm actually feeling but I do think
it's important for the bubble reason to
remind people that the carefully curated
home that they have made for themselves
is not representative of the real world
and that is a good service you can
provide to your neighbors and
journalists might be really frustrating
but they're still your neighbors so my
name is Mark Sabin I'd like to ask you a
question that goes back to what cheryl
atkinson said in her talk this morning
and she talked about the curator hers
and the question of the corporations
controlling speech there is now a law
pending I believe it's in California
where they now want to have a
governmental II developed sponsored
control curator and forced media to go
through that control process to
guarantee and determine what will be
released or not as I tell you your
thoughts on the UCM I think this is
something that people on the right need
to really monitor and be careful about
one thing that was interesting I loved
that she was giving this history of fake
news and it was so weird in the
aftermath of the election I anyone has
to acknowledge that was a surprising
election result even for people like me
who predicted it I was still surprised
because I'd kind of lost the confidence
in my prediction at the end but the way
that people ran to this idea of fake
news it was so disorienting like of
course that's not a real thing that
caused the election of Donald Trump but
they're all pretending like it is so
what was their real game plan and I
think it does come down to control of
information and the idea that if you can
judge the
you know the right news as real news and
the wrong thing as fake news you get to
control the information that people
receive and control of information is
the way that totalitarian systems
control the people and it sounds
dramatic but it's obviously happening in
social media and I think we're going to
quickly see that it that we are not well
positioned to fight against it and that
conservatives have frequently had this
idea that the only problem of censorship
is if it comes from the government and
certainly governmental censorship is a
serious problem that's not the only way
censorship can happen and they need to
be aware of what systems they
participate in that limit expression and
limit information and I think part of
that should be about how when we get our
news we make sure that we are getting it
from a good variety of sources that
we're seeking out and not just
responding to what corporations have
decided is okay and that does take more
work and also maybe less this is total
argument against interest because I run
an online publication but less
information gathering online and more
about being getting your education
through books printed publication and
the like but it's something that people
really need to be aware of that there
can be serious problems of censorship
that exist outside of a government
governmental system
hi fred bhature from Colorado and
just wondering you talked a lot about
culture and the cultural rot and things
that are going on and and you know just
living through the decades you see
things make it downturn and all that do
you think that at some point there's
going to be a there's going to have to
be a crisis point to make to bring
things back or do you believe that that
you know through starting your own
publications or institutions you can
make a gradual shift back to the middle
and or something like that do you think
that's possible or we're gonna have to
go through some kind of blood blood
thing I know by the way is Laura
Ingraham is she gonna make it and I'm
very proud of her and the company for
not like letting the bullies determine
content I think that's a really
dangerous path to go down and I hope I
would like to see actually all media
figures whether they're on left or right
think through a little bit about
corporate bullying and whether that's
something that is such a good idea in
the long run so I think that it's a bit
of an optimistic idea to think that a
crisis point might arrive and it's too
optimistic for two reasons one it might
never arrive and also you don't know how
things will actually go if a crisis
comes along so there's it's I mean I
think you can feel it in the air that
there's some domestic conflict and
there's international conflict and
certainly if something big happened
there all bets are off in terms of what
happens in the future
and hopefully what you should always be
doing also in light of this because you
never know when conflict will come is
preparing for how to handle your way
through conflict and how to make things
better at the other side of that
conflict but because it might not happen
and because it might not go the way that
you like of course the thing to do is to
build up the institution's
what I'm what I'm a little frustrated by
is how much people want to believe that
the left is open to conservative
viewpoints or open to conservative ideas
and they keep on trying to persuade and
I think that how many decades do these
institutions have to tell you they're
not interested before you realize like
maybe this isn't the way to
and why having strong institutions are
so important and because these other
institutions on the left the media and
academia are actually pretty weak it is
a great moment to build up institutions
on the right and we can learn from what
they did well and avoid their errors so
I think that's far and away the best
plan
well I'm bill Crowe from Colorado and as
a new member of the Molly Hemingway fan
club I'd like to ask you to put your
crystal ball ring your crystal ball out
and tell us what you think about the
midterms coming up almost tomorrow so
one of my one of my things I do is I
don't make predictions unless I really
have a strong idea about it it's very
frustrating to be on special report
because bret baier loves to surprise you
with a quick question about what your
prediction is about something that's
going to happen now when I make
predictions I'm actually pretty good I
mentioned that I was one of the I was
and this was not a common view out in DC
I thought Donald Trump would win the
election and I made that prediction in
January of 2016 before he won the
primary I had a good understanding of
that situation with the midterms I think
people I think people on the right are
very right to be concerned and I think
that they have I don't think that
Republican elected officials have done a
good job of managing the last year and a
half I don't think they've given enough
victories to excite the base and I think
that they've also just done some really
stupid stuff like a 1.3 trillion dollar
spending bill kind of makes you wonder
why you're voting for a Republican if
they're going to do this anyway and
failure to push back against some
progressive advancements which is not to
say and people can get really down on
Congress they've actually done a lot of
really good stuff too and you know Mitch
McConnell has handled judicial
nominations very well and he'd handled
them well going back into into the when
Scalia died which I don't think people
really got for his plan that he would
not hold hearings on any nominee and
people lost their minds and he was like
maybe you didn't hear me we're not
having hearings on the nominee and
they'd come up with all these reasons
why you had to and he was like oh I'm
sorry did you not hear me no hearings
like it's not going to happen and that
was one of the most important decisions
that brought the presidency to
Republicans and he does not get enough
credit for that
so I think people can get a little
they'd love to critique Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell it's a very difficult
caucus to manage there is there aren't
really good numbers there so what if you
care about that party what you should do
is build up the numbers to give them
some ability to actually push through
legislation but I think instead what's
happened is they played it too safe
people are demoralized and to say that
the left is exuberant is a huge
understatement
like all they've known since November 9
2016 2016 was what they would be doing
at the midterms and they are very
motivated and highly funded so I think
it's reasonable to worry about it having
said that people always make predictions
early on and there can be a turn of
events that lead to wildly different
calculus on the eve of an election
including a crisis point a you know a
war with North Korea or something else
you know that causes people to sort of
reorder what is their biggest incentive
or what they're looking to do so that
was a really long way to say I don't
know sorry
I'm Lewis house from Louisville Colorado
oh and for those who are not Coloradoans
it's not okay question it's great
Italian food there there are many
organizations that claim to be fact
checkers no the question is are there
any that are legitimate and even
balanced and in particular I'm
interested in one call I think it's pro
política do you have comments on that
Pro Publica okay I think what's
interesting about the entire
fact-checking
genre is that it really arose out of
liberal frustration that somehow George
W Bush got elected again when they were
like but we've told people he's a bad
guy
why did they not listen and any day this
was the early version of fake news oh
they believed things were real when
really we all know that George Bush is
the worst liar in the history of all
Liars and they wonder why their rhetoric
against Donald Trump doesn't go over so
well
but they built up this fact-checking
Empire based on their frustration that
people were voting Republican and I
think it shows fact checks always go
against Republicans the fact check
opinion instead of facts so they'll be
frustrated that someone has an opinion
that differs from them and they will say
oh technically it's true that the tax
code is longer than the Bible as Ted
Cruz or someone said but if you think
about it in a different way that's not
really the way to put it well that's not
a fact check that's not that's whatever
that is that's not a fact check and so
they struggle with their own limitations
that were cooked in at the beginning oh
wait I have to mention one of my
favorite ones is they rated Carly
Fiorina a liar because she published a
book called from secretary to CEO but
did you know that she didn't go straight
from secretary to CEO
so she's a liar and I think that the
entire enterprise is rotten that's my
own personal bias wait one more example
is that they raided in 2013 bill or
Barack Obama's claim that if you like
your health care plan you can keep it
they rated that lie of the year and
people say well see look they go after
Democrats but they fail to mention is
that PolitiFact judged that statement
true six times during the actual time it
mattered when people were voting based
on these things and then many years
later they said oh it turned out that
was a lot it turned out that wasn't true
but they had given credibility to the
statement when it mattered only to
backtrack later so there is a new site
actually we just talked about it on
media buzz on Sunday that analyzes fact
checks and just kind of compares like
are they actually checking facts are
they checking opinions or another
favorite of mine are they checking
predictions
you cannot fact check a prediction
because it's in the future and looking
at whether their sources for something
are credible or not and how they go
about their business but just per my own
personal view is I don't I just
fundamentally reject the entire premise
of fact-checking other people might get
more value out of them we have time for
one more question no pressure but it
should be a good question
Thank You Molly my name is John young
I'm from Littleton Colorado I wonder if
you could comment and what things we can
do as citizens to fight back against
speech and the college campuses so I
actually think that what's most
important is in your own life to
cultivate an embrace of free expression
and I thought about this with the there
was a story a few years ago with Brendan
Eich who was the CEO of Mozilla and he'd
given a small amount of money to a
campaign to define marriage as the union
of one man and one woman and he lost his
job which was not just his job he
founded the company and he was forced
out and because he refused to recant and
how easy would it have been with his
empire to say oh I shouldn't have done
that or I'm sorry I didn't realize I was
hurting feelings or something he refused
to recant he didn't say anything about
it but he just refused to do what you
were supposed to do I found this to be
one of the most inspirational moments of
the last decade people responded to it
by you know it like a lot of pundits
said good he got fired that's just the
market doing its work that would be sort
of a liberal viewpoint and libertarians
said or that was a libertarian viewpoint
the Liberals said he should have been
fired he had the wrong ideas and even
like a lot of conservatives said well
you should have the right to be wrong
but he was actually fired for being
right he was fired for saying something
true and his refusal to recant reminded
me I was actually just mentioning this
at lunch
Vaslav Havel has an essay called power
of the powerless I think it's called
it's colloquially referred to as the
greengrocer essay because he talks about
how people put up signs and communist
systems where they say workers of the
world unite nobody even knows what it
means but they know they're supposed to
put the sign up and it keeps the people
above them happy and knows they can
trust them and it keeps the people below
them confident that they can deal with
them and if someone refuses to put the
sign in it really disrupts the system
and so I think that a lot of what's
happened at universities has happened
because we ourselves self-censored and
we were afraid to say true things and we
care a lot about not offending people
which is a good virtue to be
polite but what we have lost is the
fight for truth and I think in our own
interactions with our family members our
neighbors and our colleagues we need to
make sure that we aren't losing that
very American embrace of free expression
and that we also react with happiness to
other people practicing that even when
we disagree with them that we take the
time to argue with them and that we
reinstall these values as a culture and
I think that would be the best thing we
could do and if you can't do that if you
are if that's not your gift I do think
it's important to support those people
that are doing it and to make sure that
those institutions and people who are
out there publicly do get your support
which is good to do even if you're doing
this on your own too but that's what
that's my best advice for what to do
Thanks
[Applause]